[Music]
so we're gonna talk about roe v wade
just kidding
every time
so is everybody familiar with mr elon
musk's new uh they call him the irobot
no
no i never heard of that he has another
robot he's been developing an ai robot a
very humanoid looking thing let me pull
this thing up so everybody kind of has a
reference this isn't the actual one but
this was what they used as a demo
one thing i don't understand about this
dude
is like he's on joe rogan going
ai is scary it's scary yeah and will
take us over
and he's developing these [ __ ]
i think he was talking about the
government he's talking about anybody
creating ai he's talking about that
being inevitable so in order to
understand that if it's gonna be that
that moment of singularity is gonna be
inevitable anyway then it's more
important for us to do it consciously
and then to uh symbiotically merge with
cyber electronics and stuff versus
resort on ai as its own technology
so he had talked about what the [ __ ] did
you just say dude i know that's what i
was trying to figure out
can you talk that's why you develop
things like the neural links so that you
can take computer chips and already
combine it so that you're looking at
humanoid cyborgs in the future versus
humans and robots like robocop so
instead of humans and robots in the
future where robots will take over
instead of making human robots
they're
like this yeah we don't want to be like
this you want to be like this it's a
merger together that's all you gotta do
why did you say that think more robocop
and less terminator
there we go see okay i don't smoke so i
don't [ __ ] know his words yeah geo
what okay so
uh so elamas has been working on this
and he now says that the first prototype
of his bot that he has named optimus
will be ready to showcase this prototype
on tesla's ai day this coming september
30th whoa so we are literally from his
first prototype less than three months
away from seeing the first humanoid
robot robot that is capable of at five
feet eight inches it is 125 pounds and
it can uh deadlift 150 pounds while
being able to carry 45 pounds
carry 45 pounds dude weak i got better
maxes than that [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
cyber truck man yeah yeah you know
that's what i was thinking the whole
time because of the cyber 100 bucks down
to save one it's been [ __ ] two years
it only cost 100 bucks to like pre-order
it all the 100 bucks that's why i did it
you slept on it dude
i was looking for the atv
you know the age yeah so you have to
pre-order so that you can reserve an atv
i don't give a [ __ ] about no robot man
i can't drive i guess that's it then so
then what yeah
what's the point of it or what is it so
think about uh a rope what can you do
with a robot that can constantly carry
up to 45 pounds of stuff and not have
the same uh emotions of a human that
gets tired or whatever or it can run
like for days at a time my laundry
construction construction
45 pounds though
paint
vacuum laundry all the chores errands
get the mail
[ __ ] light bulb screwing
oh those are annoying
for that
so you have a more oil so basically you
have a filipino 9th grader
just a filipino 9th grader hanging
around what if the whole time it wasn't
even a real robot it was just an actual
filipino person in like a
thing in a robot outlet and just playing
irkelbot for like years
and you put on karaoke and they just
start singing you're like wait you're
not a robot
whenever you turn away he's like trying
to [ __ ] eat
[Laughter]
she'll be so [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
so um the bot will make use of tesla's
autopilot software and will be equipped
with eight cameras to feed into the
neural network which is said to emulate
functions of human brain it uses the
cameras to evaluate surroundings by
identifying objects roots and images and
despite concerns made by people who
watch too many sci-fi films musk has
promised a non-dangerous robot capable
of boring tasks
okay i mean we're gonna need a lot of
asks
it'd be cool for like elderly people oh
oh yeah free labor yeah
that one's nice but this is better i
think it's kind of cool that there is a
um
like strength limit because it feels
less lethal it does the 3050s if it
could just run through a wall or some
[ __ ] you're like oh [ __ ] that yeah but
that looks so fun i know
how [ __ ] rad would that be
that's an advertisement this one can run
through three rolls
i would invite you guys over and i'd be
like check this [ __ ] out and then he
[ __ ] crashes through you guys would
be so impressed
you just have drywall at her house
absolutely yeah just build drywall i
would just market it as a crossing guard
you can hit
but think about all the jobs that are
gonna be taken cause i'm [ __ ] mad are
you just laughing
oh yeah great
or the time given back to people either
you're gonna be innovated into a job or
out of a job and this is definitely out
of a job well that's how it's always is
right yeah you know well there is a
there's a shortage
there's a fast food shortage we need
more fast food workers and this is a
great job
for the robots a little fry maker
dang it takes like 40 years before
they're smart enough to like make a
sandwich the right way the logic of like
having it not just be machines doing it
but still humanoid things to [ __ ] it up
oops burn your burger
that'll be 5 45. i want to make it more
real who do i complain to my manager
he's programmed to like slightly [ __ ] up
sometimes too you throw pickles on no
matter what hey i gave you a twenty man
did you i don't remember
oh my god it's so realistic it's so
realistic i love it
i think that was the premise in uh will
smith's eye robot does anybody remember
that i haven't seen it i forgot it was
old i guess that's the end of that
conversation i forgot it was old but in
the very very beginning right it's like
um everybody kind of has their own
uh ai robot that and then it's his mom
or his grandma or something like that
that has the newest version of the robot
that helps out with different things and
he's got this very like chip on her
shoulder like i don't trust robots
because he's like half a robot spoiler
alert
was that what the what ending was he was
he was a robot it wasn't the ending but
definitely like two thirds in the movie
i know i was about to watch it because
oh we can edit that out
no for me you can't edit my ears
see that's why you got the neural link
what is it set to release is it going to
be open to the public is it just for
companies prototypes comes out in
september which probably means it's not
going to actually release a consumer
republic forever are there any other
competitors that are like
like neck and neck i heard something
jeff bezos has just started amazon robot
yeah the alexa robot i don't doubt it
like amazon's always been working on
like ai robots that do deliveries within
the warehouse and stuff like that anyway
yeah they do yeah but them shits look
[Music]
that's the type of filipinos that they
have
did you guys remember his like
demonstration to the cyber truck when he
was saying like you can't shadow the
windows and he goes and he [ __ ]
smashes and it just shatters it'd be so
rad if that happened with the robot just
kills everyone in the audience
murders everyone it'd be so rad if he
just fails
absolutely he would have to be
demonstrating the opposite where he's
like don't worry if it goes out of
control you could just kill it and then
oh no
revolts oh my god on stage he should
hand everyone an axe
so they're just like [ __ ] yeah and
then no one can kill it
that's true if you need to kill the
robot just pour some water on it and be
fine they just keep trying to smash it
the robot just goes harder harder
[Laughter]
if anything that's going to be the robot
that takes over the world the sexual one
yeah a hundred percent processes pain is
pleasure yeah or because it's going to
be in everybody's house very quickly
yeah yeah and everything everything you
try to do to stop it just makes it come
more yeah
wait come in which way
everywhere
up here down everybody dies by drowning
anyways um so disgusting i can't believe
you made that joke yeah joe that is
disgusting
that's the line you're not in a climate
for jokes like that yeah
there's two ladies in the room dude
we're talking about ejaculate dude
exactly okay so uh elon actually said
um because like you said he there
obviously speculation that there is a
danger element to it he said quote we're
setting it
such that it is at a mechanical level at
a physical level
you can run away from it and most likely
overpower it i like the most likely how
they test it you can run away from it
some people fail some people don't they
only walk that's right
it would be the funniest thing if he
goes all right i'm going to show you
guys a demonstration of the robot now
come along and then he just takes
everyone to california adventure where
they launch that spiderman
that's it yeah that's it he goes what do
you think
the one that just broke
it's like people like this is it and
then he looks and he goes you know it's
modeled after tom holland
[Laughter]
if the robot was affordable would you
guys buy one yeah of course i have no
[ __ ] robot what would you do just the
flex just the flex put it in the carpool
seat of your tesla so you can just drop
a coat hanger at your house sure just
throw your [ __ ] sweaters on
instead of stimulus checks they just
everyone gets one of those to help with
like daily [ __ ]
if it could bust through walls i would
dress it up as the kool-aid man and then
program it to say oh yeah and when i
would come to your house i would just
[ __ ] hit the button bust through and
go oh yeah it's like joe's here you're
not invited you just want to roll up
that bus through walls yeah and say
oh
yeah and that never gets old for you all
of our buildings are just just
demolished she's been here your society
is gone
it's just kool-aid madrid everywhere
every [ __ ] vietnamese restaurant
you